what's up guys bang bang this
conversation with David Mercer from lmax
group is awesome he really really
understands the institutional world and
he understands how important regulation
is as you're paying attention to this
conversation remember that David has
infrastructure that's trading billions
and billions of dollars of Bitcoin and
other cryptocurrencies every single
month and almost every single major
institution in the world uses his
products to trade you may not have heard
of lmac's group before but that's
because they don't service any sort of
consumer facing retail investor they
only service institutions so getting
into the mind of somebody like this who
talks to these institutions every single
day especially during a bear Market is
incredibly valuable hope you guys enjoy
this interview make sure you like the
video subscribe to the channel and I'll
see you guys on the other side David
we're in a bear Market uh prices have
come down significantly 70 to 90 percent
in uh in the crypto markets and bear
markets usually Shake confidence how do
we know that these assets are here to
stay and what are you hearing from the
institutional world are they running
scared or are they like no this is going
to be here in five or ten years look I
think is fear is pervading capital
markets at the moment so it's not crypto
right but it was ever that's you know
out of crises comes strong companies and
I'd say specifically in crypto because
that's what you want to talk about today
I'd say the confidence levels are
arguably higher than they were this time
last year there are more institutions
more bigger names entering the space in
2022 than there was in 2021. that should
be a sign of confidence now let's put
let's layer on
some reality on that
the sense of urgency may have gone so in
21 it was like look what you're missing
out on and it was how do we get there
quickly now it's
how do we get there correctly but
certainly from the conversations we have
and from our traditional institutional
counterparties they've got bigger teams
than ever looking at crypto blockchain
and defy than they did last year
um and they're showing a lot more intent
certainly in our conversations there's a
lot more intent for them to
straddle
the whole of crypto and blockchain
Technology rather than just Chase
returns for customers that might have
been the case in 2021. I think a lot of
people will be surprised to hear you say
that while prices were going up uh there
was confidence but actually the
confidence is deeper now when prices
have fallen is that a kind of proxy for
people want to buy cheap and sell high
or is that something around it's just
timing and it took them years and years
and years of seeing these assets out in
the market and seeing the volatility to
get comfortable to be able to actually
start to allocate to it you know you've
almost got to ignore the crypto Market
yeah I've got to look at these
institutions I mean they're large they
criticize at times for being
slow but it's just
the nature of their scale so it is that
Al Pacino uh Speech they move inch by
inch and they move the same number of
inches and 21
and the same level of inches in 2022
which means they're getting much closer
much closer to delivering product the
way I look at it across
probably the most significant
Gatekeepers in capital markets the banks
is there's four things they do in every
asset class they invest in it they trade
it for themselves and for on behalf of
their clients they clear it for
themselves and for their clients and
then they store it or they Bank it
they're a clearer for it today they are
doing about 45 of that in that they've
all the Box bracket banks have invested
in crypto and blockchain all of them are
trading the derivative for their clients
and about half of them are trading it
clearing it for their clients so the one
thing they haven't done yet is store it
but they're making steps towards filling
in that Matrix and offering a hundred
percent of those services to their
customers in the next decade what's
fascinating to me about that is you guys
were very very early to helping service
a number of these institutional clients
as you see the them push deeper into the
industry kind of take on more of the
potential things they could do in with
these assets do you see the addressable
Market that these institutions see in
crypto expanding or has there always
been just this massive Market
opportunity and kind of that inch by
inch uh approach to it so is the market
expanding or are we actually just seeing
them kind of capture more of what they
already saw was there I think their
addressable Market is bigger for the
first time ever people who've started to
talk to me and us about options in
crypto for the first time ever these
institutions are addressing D5 or
certainly understand thinking how do we
play a part in B5 how can we be
liquidity providers in D5 how can we get
involved in stock borrowing and lending
in D5 so probably if you look back three
years it was okay how do we access
Bitcoin how do we access ethereum how do
we access the spot market and the
Futures market now they're looking at
all these other opportunities are going
to happen a minute there could be a big
financing marketing now don't get me
wrong it's not the financing Market
that's seen some blow ups in in crypto
over the uh over this year it's actually
stock borrowing and lending and
financing of transactions is one of the
biggest parts of all institutions
Revenue certainly Bank revenues you know
if you actually go into the detailed
profit and loss and that's what they're
looking at now so they're realizing that
this spot Market that you know ton of
market cap of whatever a trillion
dollars isn't to be an end of it all
it's the leverage of that and it's a
derivative of that so I think they're
really starting to address the the
second and third derivatives and
realizing that everything they do in
traditional finance will come to pass in
crypto and maybe more so I think that's
what's encouraged them to invest more
than ever and which makes me think that
their adoption in 22 and and the
coverage in 22 is greater than the 70.
so if we go back to the internet and
kind of the rise uh in the mid 90s you
could have told your parents hey I'm
quitting my job and I'm gonna go work at
an internet company and I think a lot of
people said you know what's an internet
company and there was a very kind of
strong Line in the Sand there was
companies that were on the internet and
a company that were not on the internet
today if you talked about a company just
everything is accompanied and of course
they use the internet is that how you
see this playing out over the next
decade or so is that today there are
kind of crypto native asset managers
there's crypto native projects there's
crypto native assets themselves but
eventually we will actually see these
banks will all use this technology all
of the asset managers will have
traditional assets plus these new assets
and it won't be so much aligned in the
sand as it's just an asset it's just an
asset management firm short answer which
would make for a very very boring
interview is yes for sure I mean it's a
bit like I get slightly miffed and
people say hey David you run a fintech
company well no I'm in capital markets
and
or finance and technology is essential
to everything we do
so when you look at
what's happening in these institutions I
mean some of the biggest banks in the
world are now swapping or getting assets
off balance sheet using blockchain
technology and using a private coin
between those Banks so there's something
to realize the the use cases for
blockchain that's before I get back to
an old hobby horse of mine which is you
know the blow ups you've seen in
traditional Finance over the last three
four decades I've always been because of
problems around settlement payment and
Reconciliation it's clear to everyone
that blockchain can help with that
blockchain technology can help with all
of that so it's a bit I I think maybe in
the early 2000s certainly in the second
decade of the Millennium people were
saying you know if you didn't have a
fintech or a mobile strategy you didn't
have a business well guess what right
now for any business if you don't have a
blockchain blockchain strategy a
blockchain team you will not succeed you
simply won't be here in 10 or 20 years
and that's why I think the biggest
institution in the world are addressing
it now they're investing more than ever
they've got bigger teams than ever
looking at it because it is just the
internet right is this the third wave I
don't know I happen to think we might be
in a very fortunate generation you know
we've waited a couple of hundred years
for the Second Industrial Revolution
which was the internet
um I think blockchain technology is
going to be the third great one and I
think everyone is now aware of that so
whether they are crypto evangelists or
not whether you see the headlines about
XYZ you know Bank CEO calls it this that
or the other what a particular asset
this thing or the other one thing is
clear they're all investing in
blockchain and this will be you know the
next internet and they all have to have
a strategy for it that pervades through
all of their organizations front office
to back office so when I think over a
really long time period uh it's pretty
obvious that hey look they're coming
they're going to be here for a long time
they're not going to invest all of their
uh head count their time their energy
their money into doing this but along
that road uh it can get quite bumpy uh
we've seen things like three arrows
Capital Luna Terra and many others that
uh probably have almost put up warning
signs or stop signs for some
organization saying look there is risk
ahead be careful as you go into this
industry how have you seen those kind of
uh uh specific uh situations play out
with the excitement of the organizations
or the institutions are they still just
as excited and they understand that
that's a small part of the industry or
are you having to have conversations
with them saying look here's what
happened let us explain to you what
we're doing to mitigate these types of
risks in the future like what are you
seeing there mostly they've ignored
those those failed projects right
because they weren't involved sometimes
a slightly haughty approach or arrogant
approach that is ah that was crazy
Whoever thought it would work actually a
lot of them went weren't um dumb ideas
but in everything you know if you talk
to most people don't react that way
because all of them invested in
95.com stocks and they got lucky with a
couple right and 90 odd went to the wall
and they made money on the couple sorry
for the United States listeners a couple
is two as opposed to the few
um so yeah they go right with Skype they
got right with Amazon that's it and
there's a whole bunch of other ones
pets.com that didn't work
um so I think they've largely ignored it
and in fact as an industry as a crypto
industry if I'm allowed to be part of
that
um for a second is perhaps we've over
dramatized it you know unless I go into
the details of those there were
certainly flaws in there
um but I think
you know to build scale
in any business you'd have two things
you need to have good grasp of the
fundamentals and you need to have
imagination now within the crypto
industry there's an abundance of
imagination and I think that's fantastic
that that were a fantastic concept that
we'll convey through our Capital markets
but perhaps there wasn't enough
knowledge of the fundamentals it was as
if we had reinvented
borrowing and lending well we haven't
ultimately the fundamentals of the same
as stock boring lending have been around
for four centuries so I think the lesson
to us in the industry but by the way the
guys in traditional Finance have learned
it many times over is get a good grasp
of the fundamentals and I think if you
want to talk about those three
um then it is probably a failure to
address the fundamentals but the
imagination is what's driving the
interest for all of us in the industry
and it's the imagination which is
starting to take hold within traditional
Finance yeah it's fascinating this whole
idea of like recreating uh or relearning
uh lessons of the past but that is true
for all of human history and so I think
it's clear to call out like that's not
abnormal uh but it still is important to
understand uh what works in traditional
Finance what doesn't work uh and why
right it goes also towards a regulation
I I continue to say you know things like
uh transparency rules or things like uh
disclosure rules they're there for a
reason at some point they weren't there
people were doing things and so uh
there's a group of people who said hey
we should probably put this in place uh
because of a b or c reason do you see
regulations still being a hurdle for a
lot of these organizations or have they
gotten past that and they're now
comfortable actually kind of
participating without more regulatory
Clarity they're not positive but I think
more than ever they are trying to
influence it
um it's just a fact that the biggest
organizations the biggest regulated
organizations
um on Wall Street
and in the city of London across the
globe need that regulatory determinism
they need to understand they need some
of the rules of the game
so they can add to the value of the game
and without that regulated determinism
they simply can't proceed but what I'd
say is right now so get ready everyone
they're readying themselves
right they are acting as if there was
regulation in terms of the preparation
the connectivity understanding the
product coming up with the structures
right
I can name probably six of the largest
banks in the world who if if and when
they get
the green for go sign I think they can
be active throughout all the markets in
crypto within a month
so that they're readying themselves but
they do need those approvals be at the
cftc the SEC or the FED right they are
going to need the rules of the game to
be clarified the argument need that
regulation determinism
um I'm hopeful and I'm expectant that we
will get there but look we're going to
be impatient in crypto land we're
probably unexpected this year we're not
going to see it this year I'd like to
see there'd be some I'd like to think
there'd be some sign of regulated
determinism in 2023 I think will be much
much closer if I had to bet in the
floodgates
to true institutionalization of crypto
will be 2024 and the key that opens or
unlocks uh those floodgates will be
regulation that is understandable and is
built on the key pillars that currently
exist within traditional Finance what's
fascinating to me is uh there's a common
phrase in the industry bear markets are
for building uh you all in past bear
markets have built a ton of
infrastructure and then obviously reap
the benefits of that as we moved into
bull markets what are you all building
now what do you find to be kind of the
biggest areas of focus that you think
will actually prove to be great
Investments on your part over the coming
years I can't so I can't tell you
everything answer you've got to keep
something up my sleeve just up here
somewhere but um no look we're we're
proceeding as we have done for the last
five years I mean we launched our Max
digital in 2018 so it's the fifth year
of operation I'd be uh pretty average
CEO if I rested on my laurels and
thought the product in 2025 would be the
same as 2018. if it's the same I would
have failed so for me 2022 is over
um I most of the way through 2023 now so
in terms of what I know where we're
building what we're producing and all
everything is about enabling Market
access for the customers that I know the
customers that I know are institutions
so what have we done launched Futures
right institutional Futures in Europe
that are 24 7. what's after that so
they're Fiat settle Futures what's after
that move into physical futures of
course what else have we done you know
we've started to seed the defy
environments we have we have helped with
the
um growth of the pith Network right
which now has 75 apps built on Solana
within that so what else are we doing
we're trying to create clear solutions
for all those institutions so they can
access spot and derivatives
um within crypto we're building out a
much better custodian offering which
guess what is the Bedrock for that
clearing what I mean everyone wants to
be a custodian I'm not looking at as a
as a revenue generator I'm looking at as
a as a facilitator to my core exchange
business it's so I can list a lot more
coins a lot more tokens and because in
order to list them I have to be able to
store them so that's what we're working
on right now plus adding distribution
capabilities
um across the globe so I've added
um distribution Partners in Asia in the
Americas and in Europe and we we must
continue to do that and because that's
the key to any system of businesses and
Quality Distribution but it's building
the product continue to build that
product out and then ultimately getting
in getting in the hands of the customers
I know those institutions as quickly as
possible so yeah we um I'd say more of
my company more of our Max group is
focused on the crypto side of the
business the LMX digital side of the
business than that has ever been the
case yeah uh it's funny to hear you talk
about distribution there's a saying in
the technology world uh first-time
entrepreneurs focus on the product
second time entrepreneurs focus on
distribution what's unique about you all
is you seem to be doing both you
continue to iterate and innovate uh on
the product side but distribution is a
very big part of what you all do talk a
little bit as to how you've seen that
work well uh and maybe some things that
you've tried in the past that haven't
worked as well going and bringing a new
asset class to these institutions I like
that I like that saying
you know it's very hard to focus on
everything and sometimes when people go
on about customer customer
it's kind of business school BS right
because ultimately one of the greatest
successes of our lifetime Starbucks did
not talk to any customer right we did
not know we wanted to spend five bucks
on a frothy coffee and 20 years ago they
did they didn't speak to any customers
um but you know look we're all about
Market access you've got to build great
products and get it into their hands
what uh what doesn't work so give me a
give me I'll try and give an example of
things that didn't work is to cut out
some intermediation layers so go go to
the End customer and speak an
Institutional language to them well that
doesn't work right I've tried that a few
times so for example I stepped this is
going back and back in I stepped all the
way back from going straight B to C
because I didn't speak the language or I
didn't distill the message well enough
to that segment so then what I said was
okay let's be B2B
right let's speak the same language as
that as that broker or that B2B business
and then they can disseminate it to a
wider group some of my biggest customers
are now makes digital today would be
retail facing Brokers or payment
providers and quite simply if the End
customer came directly to me they'd
probably be disappointed with my service
because I wasn't giving them the bells
and whistles they'd expect so it's it's
actually it's not just a sales messaging
or or the marketing message or the
latest sales guy is actually finding the
right partners that can explain the
message
in a language of that segment and that
customer understands so like I think we
could we would do well in the uh
in the industry to think about that all
right and build
products or messages that are
appropriate for the segment we wish to
address and it's interesting to me
recently people are all talking about oh
can we have a broker on an exchange you
know can there be new rules about doing
that
in the United States of America one of
the largest exchanges in the world just
said okay we're going to set up a
brokerage house
I'd recommend I'd recommend that they
didn't only answered it because it's a
different language it's just a very
different language it's a bit like
though I look at technology you know we
need to evolve if I'm talking to crypto
evangelist now and I talk about on-prem
on-premises technology they've got to
look at me like I'm a dinosaur but guess
what on-prem technology is what's
required for low latency exchanges
that's what we do that's what we're good
at that's what the biggest exchanges in
the world are good at but that's not
going to work in the future of tranfi
defy and crypto brokerages it's all
gonna be cloud-based and people are
going to want to access it from all over
the all over the the world so look I put
a couple of things in there to get a
distribution
um and Technology but you've just got to
keep moving ahead and I think for even
for all guys like me we've got to try
and keep abreast of the new way that
people want to consume information you
know that I mean the way people have
consumed
um your information your broadcasts over
the last three to five years has changed
and will continue to change and evolve
myself and everyone at lmax group and in
our industry must do the same yeah I
completely agree that it's changing and
uh it's kind of wild to see a change
even month to month year to year right
uh but but definitely there's a shift to
uh uh to digital and those who are able
to kind of get ahead of it will benefit
greatly my last question for you is as
you look out over the next five years uh
kind of encapsulating the rest of
whatever this bear market ends up being
and into the next bull market what's the
one thing that you're looking forward to
that you think people may not be really
talking about but you think is really
important is there something that you
can kind of pinpoint and say man you
know we should really be more focused on
X or or this thing is much more
important than people realize yeah put
in the boring stuff and it is back right
down at the heart of traditional Finance
right it's credit it's clearing right
that's I'm spending an awful lot of time
thinking about that designing product
for it and working out Solutions with
institutions to access the crypto space
today
um quite simply that's the key is follow
the thread follow the follow the assets
right follow the threat of the assets
there are 200 trillion dollars of Assets
in custody today right follow that
thread how did they get how did they get
there why is it invested in those asset
classes
what intermediaries did they use
right to store it where they store it
follow that thread and suddenly you open
up all of those assets
having access to crypto so that's it
look it's a dull answer I'd love to say
I'm sure somebody will say this
blockchain or that blockchain
um this repo model or this D5 product I
promise you if you want the the three
R's that are so key in every industry if
you want repeatable resilient
responsible returns then you've got to
address what's right at the core of that
right and that's all I try and do at
this group is produce those three hours
right so responsible uh repeatable
resilient returns so if you manage to do
that then you'll be okay as an
institution so that's really what
excites me because I think we're on the
cusp where my cuss was an industry of
solving it
it hasn't been solved for the last 14
years and since the since the Bitcoin
white paper book we're on the cusp and
if we solve it then that wall that
divide between uh
Trad fight and crypto will have gone and
if you me and everyone else in the
industry manages to get rid of that
partition wall then there's no limit to
what can be achieved in crypto and D5
that's the game my friend where can we
find people or where can I send people
to find you on the internet or find out
more about omax group
I always get told off for this but it's
lmax.com and it's mercer.david at
lmax.com
all right thank you so much I appreciate
it we'll do it again in the future
good to see you Anthony thank you